okay
now I would say we had a pretty few big
Bombshells dropped over the course of
the last five episodes there was like
there's a lot and there's a lot to
happen a lot went down in the last five
episodes right so we met a bunch of new
characters we got a bunch of like
Secrets unveiled a lot of things came
come to came to light
that we previously didn't know about
before so yeah we got a quite a bit to
talk about but hey everybody how's
everybody doing I hope everybody is
doing okay
before we just get into the whole review
we'll wait a second for more people to
come in
so no one misses anything but anyway
yeah so I feel like
the show definitely took a turn like
after I don't know like episode 11 or 10
or something and it got really
I feel like this this this half of the
show has been a lot better
than I feel like the first
10 episodes so yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's gonna be freaking
fun
um
yeah so a few things I will say
um there are still changes from the book
and that is to be expected with a an
adaptation of any kind
um a few things have been like mixed
around and changed and by the way before
we get going to spoilers so if you're
watching this right now and if you have
not seen uh the show if you're not
caught up then there will be spoilers
and there may be some book spoilers but
we're going to try and keep book
spoilers like just kind of on the low
someone says hello fellow bugs hello
indeed hello indeed
so much happened like even just starting
from episode 16. like episode 16 just
goes up it's just I feel like episode 16
is kind of a banger right and then
episode 18 is really good
um episode 17 is pretty good episode 17
is really good right 17 is the one we
have like the big big moment where it's
like big secret and there's also a big
secret revealed in episode 20 that we'll
get to we also meet a major major
character we meet Mike Evans finally in
episode 19 we'd heard his voice before
but Mike Evans
it has a major role to play in all of
this and if you don't know about about
Mike Evans and like oh
you will soon
so yeah we've had a lot of really good
ones so
the First new character that we meet in
episode 16.
is
this guy Wei Chang so this is Sean you
face husband and we we meet him we don't
learn that much about him in episode 16
we learned that he is obsessed
obsessed with solving the three body
problem and we know that that has
something to do with why Sean ufe
married him right uh like we meet them
we see them initially and it's like um
there doesn't seem to be that much love
and by the way Dasha is also why he's
like they don't seem like they
love each other that much so like what
actually is going on with this marriage
because they have a very weird dynamic
so we meet him in episode 16 and he is
trying super hard to solve the three
ready problem he's got this screen
that's constantly showing it he's
obsessed obsessed he's got papers all
over everywhere he's sleeping on the
floor and Shawnee fan just kind of just
lets him live like this and it's not
clear why initially
um but we have panhand coming in
um
who threatens him he wants him to stop
his stop his calculations he like shoots
his computer he like threatens to kill
him he's like if you don't stop this I'm
gonna kill you and it's like really
weird and freaky and it's like why is
panhand doing this so we learn over the
course of these five episodes also about
the different
sections of ETO which is really really
interesting in uh the book and they're
definitely doing it justice in the show
I think and showing like how even within
this organization there's a lot going on
so we've got three different factions of
ETO three different factions let me just
take a sip of this
so we've got the survivors so
we've the crazy thing is by this point
in the show we still don't know exactly
what ETO is and I don't want to totally
explore it so we're just going to go
with the information that we have on the
show so first off we got the survivors
we don't know much about them yet we
don't know much about the survivors but
their name kind of suggests that they're
interested in their own Survival and we
even see like panhand kind of scoff at
the survivors all the stupid survivors
we don't really care about the survivors
that much whatever then we got
the redemptionist
right so the Redemption is have one take
on how they're to serve the Lord right
we keep getting mention of the lord it's
obviously referring to the farmer we
it's pretty obvious that they're
referencing some kind of alien being or
alien civilization at this point right
so um the redemptionist and the
Adventists have different ideas on how
to serve the Lord essentially without
spoiling everything that's going on
um so the Adventist take is more like is
more of a screw humanity take the
Adventists are kind of just like we
don't like Humanity humanity is Unworthy
of taking care of the earth look what
we've done forget about the Adventists
so that's what I mean that's forget
about the Redemption is so that's what
the Adventists think and panhand is an
Adventist so he's like humans suck don't
worry about solving the three-body
problems through that and then we got
the other side of the coin we got Sean
youthan shanifey I mean so Sean you fake
her whole thing is she is a
redemptionist and the redemptionists are
all about like hey
maybe you it's not screw Humanity maybe
we can serve the life without giving it
away right so she's trying to solve the
three-body problem and obviously what's
being presented in the game
is the world of the farmer right so um
she thinks that if she can solve the the
Redemption is to like if we can solve
the three-body problem then um the
farmer can just like stay where they are
and they don't have to like come here
and like screw all of our stuff and
maybe they can even help us uh solve
some of our issues so that's the
redemptionist take essentially so
um the redemptionist and the Adventists
are kind of are definitely opposites
within the organization and they're
really really like vying for who has
power over the organization all right
and so then we got the major bombshell
that was revealed in episode 17 which
was that
yeah wengie is actually the leader of
the organization ETO just flat out she's
a leader of all of them she's the
commander and
um yeah that's the deal but the question
is
the question that's running throughout
all of these episodes and still I don't
think has been answered is
which side is she on
what side is yahwinji on within the
organization is yahwinji a Survivor is
yawinji and aventis or is yawinji a
redemptionist and I don't think it's
totally clear right uh in episode 16 we
hear the voice of Mike Evans and he
basically says that oh it doesn't matter
you know what side she's on I mean she's
the commander like she's not on
anybody's side or whatever but I she
definitely has a side right she
definitely has a side so the big
question is whose side is she on we know
that she's the commander of ETO so it's
kind of like oh my God that's such a big
thing like how do you get from where we
last see her in the red Coast to being
commander of ETO and then we get a
little bit of that backstory by episode
20 as well
so that's the big secret and um we have
this is where things are rearranged a
little bit basically we get the same
stuff in the book but I feel like it's
rearranged it happens differently so for
instance we don't go back to the red
Coast at this point in the book right
all of this
stuff that's happening doesn't have it
doesn't happen at the red Coast so
that's kind of a little bit of
difference but it doesn't really matter
at all
um so we have a return to the red Coast
we also have
Adventists totally they're totally
trying to kill uh the Sean ufe so
um The Avengers do not want Shawnee Fair
around they're trying to assassinate her
we gotta really
honestly tense Scene It was kind of a
scene that you've seen before and other
stuff maybe but it's always uh really
tense when you have that moment where
it's like someone's in an enclosed space
and they have no place nowhere to escape
they've got nowhere to escape from and
then you've got someone on the outside
that's going to kill them as soon as
they leave and it's like ah yeah I hate
that situation right so it's like that
was really tense
um and you got um
yeah but you got but it seems like yeah
Wendy's got people
within ETL we don't okay look I'm
getting ahead of myself so we don't
fully still yet know the politics of the
organization in ETO and all that stuff
we know that there's infighting and we
know that there's people that are loyal
to yeah wenji uh we know that there's
people that are loyal to the different
factions right so I mean it's not it's
not like a simple thing where it's like
you've got like one group and everybody
in that group is totally homogeneous and
everybody listens to one person you've
got people that are loyal to different
factions I'm sure yeah wenji has people
that are loyal to her specifically
um and none of it is exactly like
straightforward or clear at this point
uh in the show
um
but yeah
so yeah we got we had an assassination
attempt in episode I believe 17 on yeah
wenji uh not yet wenji but um
and then whoever yeah wengie's girl was
prevented the assassination attempt I
don't know who that random character was
that girl but she totally like handled
that guy like
she totally made short work of that guy
in an instant so that was pretty fun to
see
um so yeah we get to episode 18. and
yawinji is basically calling everybody
back to the Red Coach she's meeting a
bunch of people at the red Coast she's
going to meet uh Wang at the red Coast
she's uh hanging out with shiny Faye at
the red coast and then in episode 19 she
meets like somebody else and we'll get
to that just in a second so in episode
another bombshell dropped this episode
Another bombshell that like
really moves the story along and episode
18 happens so we're getting more of the
backstory of yawinji and her time at the
red Coast
um they tell her several different
things about what they're doing that are
true right so it's like oh we're doing
this oh we're doing that but none of it
is the actual purpose and they debate
and they argue and they deliberate a
very long time about
whether or not to tell yeah wenji what
the heck is going on even at the red
Coast
but they eventually do and honestly
um it's so cool and I really love this
concept because as a kid I've always
been really curious and really
interested in the idea of aliens and
extraterrestrials so the purpose of the
red Coast is seti the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence and when I
was very young I would always think like
oh God dream job be to work at seti talk
to aliens I'm going to be the first
person to communicate with aliens and
discover aliens
um so that's really cool so the actual
purpose of the red base of the red Coast
base isn't like to spy on enemy vessels
or any of that stuff
it's just to communicate with aliens
potentially potentially
um so we learned that and that's really
cool but according to yeah wenji and
this isn't true we know the show
wouldn't exist If This Were true
according to yahwinji they never
contacted anyone right according to yeah
wenji
the signal was never strong enough and
no one would ever be able to hear it
humans are too insignificant
we're just a tiny little bubble in this
giant thing of space we're too
insignificant for anybody to ever notice
this weak signal coming from the base
that's what she tells Wang but it kind
of seems like it's not true if we got
all the if we've got the ETO
organization which we still don't know
what it stands for
um and they're worshiping some kind of
Lord From Outer Space so it seems like
someone somewhere did manage to make
contact
so someone is saying episodes 20 through
30 are already out I did hear that they
were just going to release them all but
maybe not on YouTube maybe on like the
Vicky or somewhere else where it's
streaming but yeah I did hear that that
was a rumor but maybe that actually
happened I don't know I have to check my
Discord which you guys can also check my
Discord sure someone maybe James saw
will post a link to my Discord in the
chat but yeah all of your three body
problem info I at least we're always
sharing like all the the news bits and
all the interesting things that happen
over on the Discord so that they keep me
up to date actually on everything that's
going on I mean the Discord told me
about this show I didn't even know this
show was happening but yeah someone says
episode 30 is out if you don't want the
subtitles you can't you can watch it
elsewhere
yeah
so yeah it already happened the episodes
are out and yeah so we're gonna be
devouring them in a timely manner and
reviewing them on this channel so yeah
we'll see that when that happens
but yeah where were we where were we
where were we yeah um anyway search for
extraterrestrials
is so cool to me and if I was yawinji
when I heard that I would have just like
been so happy to work at the base but we
don't know what happened from that point
on well there's a gap there's a gap in
the story and then we have yawinji
meeting Mike Evans later in her life
right so there's a gap we don't know
what happened after that just yet in the
story and so we get to episode 19.
and we have we have an we have an
amazing
character introduction we have a epic
character introduction that we have not
seen yet we've heard his voice but we
have not seen this character his shadow
has been over everything though his
shadow the shadow of Mike Evans and let
me tell you what Mike Evans so far the
way they're presenting him in the show
is uh seeming like more of a villain
than even Yao wenji so
uh let's see someone says episode 22
through 30 are only available through
the 10 cent web TV app by paying eight
dollars but you can only watch for like
a day or two huh
okay well we'll see about that we'll see
about I'll check on that after the
stream but anyways so yeah everything
about the way they're filming Mike Evans
the way he speaks uh the Shadows on his
face they want him the creators of the
show I mean uh they definitely want
I always forget to change my slides they
they definitely want Mike Evans to be
betrayed as the villain right so
definitely he's got like some Sinister
happenings interesting hair too pretty
cool hair pretty cool hair
um so Mike Evans
basically the big reveal here is that
get wenji isn't the only
leader of ATL
right she's the commander but there's
other people that have Loyals in ATL so
Mike Evans is the leader
of the Adventist Mike Evans is also the
funder of ETO so way back in the day
when ya wenji when they funded when they
when she created ETO Mike Evans this guy
was the guy that gave her all the money
to do it
he had the money to make it happen he
was like he had a rich dad he had the
money to make it happen it was something
like that I forget exactly what the deal
with how he got his money but he funded
ETO he funded the organization and so it
looked over the course of that time yeah
wenji and he have developed differences
maybe there there have been kind of
schismed in the organization so things
have changed things aren't quite so
simple as they used to be anymore you
got varying
got very various leaders various
motivations various ways in which people
think how we deal with the Lord and how
we worship the Lord so it's it's it's
weird and interesting and it gets a lot
more complicated from this point on
because it's not just yeah wenji ruling
over ETO and they're just like evil and
they want to help the Lord over Humanity
it's not just that it's a lot more
complicated it's a lot more deep and
everybody has like different ways of
thinking
um and everybody thinks about it a
slightly different way which thus to me
that's what's that's really interesting
that's what's really interesting in the
book and that's what's interesting here
it's right so you've got the survivors
you've got the Adventist and you've got
the redemptionist they're all different
but they all have one thing in coming
they're choosing the Lord over Humanity
at the end of the day so like what makes
someone be willing to betray all of
humanity and the answer is a lot of
different things everybody has their own
different thing like so the survivors
are like okay the Lord's coming anyway
and we don't want to be treated badly so
like uh we're gonna help out the Lord if
he treats us good so you have to
basically the survivors are the pygmies
the pygmies of the of ETO uh and then
you got the redemptionist
um the Redemption is to kind of like the
suck UPS the Redemption is they're kind
of like the suck UPS I guess you would
say they're like oh we'll help you in
any way we can Lord we'll like fix your
solar system one we'll help you anyway
and then you got the Adventist right and
those are the ones that are just
spiteful right
um it's like you're choosing mom because
you're mad at dad right it's like yo
screw you or screw you with Humanity I'm
gonna support the
um the Lord actually so yeah so that
that's I feel like is this most
simplistic the most layman's term uh
breakdown of of the organization and
exactly what's going on without totally
entirely spoiling everything right right
without totally spoiling everything so
um
the inner workings of the organization
are just are really interesting is is
what I'm trying to get to
um so
by episode 20 we get when we get to
episode 20 we learn
exactly how witching and Shawnee Faye
met right and it's kind of an
interesting story it's kind of an
interesting story in fact we actually
learn way more about this guy
in the show than we do in the book right
we don't I don't I don't recall seeing
very much of his backstory right so we
learned that he was
kind of he's kind of been really good at
math his whole life right he's really
really intelligent when it comes to math
he can solve the problems without even
having to think about it he's kind of
got like that crazy mental skill right
um
but he's kind of bored with his life
eventually and he's just like ah
whatever I'm just gonna whatever until
he encounters the three body problem
this crazy problem in math he's like how
can I solve this and somehow somehow
someway uh Shawnee fan sees this so she
realizes that he's trying to solve the
three writer problem and she's
immediately like you're trying to solve
the three-body problem you have a
different approach she I think she was
more interested in the fact that his
approach to solving it was different
than anybody else she'd ever seen and at
this point in time she had already been
like found by the organization she had
already been working on this but she'd
never seen anybody quite like him that
was like oh my God he's like
he might really actually be the one to
solve it so that's the reason they
actually get married right it has
nothing to do with them like falling in
love or anything like that it's like
he's trying to solve this he's obsessed
and she's also obsessed in a way but
she's trying to help the Lord so she's
giving him whatever he can to try and
help him solve it like she's hired all
these other people to try and help solve
it and it's like they're kind of
spinning circles
and the big big big big
huge
huge thing that's revealed in episode
20. is that it's all for nothing the
game
the point of the game
the point of the game is revealed here's
the game is it's so you realize that
there is no three body problem not that
there is no three bedroom but that it's
unsolvable you cannot solve the
three-body problem it's impossible to
calculate the motion of three orbits so
whatever the heck it's it's just
straight up impossible you cannot do it
um so um
the redemptionist their whole thing
they're out of luck you can't solve it
you cannot find a way to predict
um the motion of the sons of the Lord's
Homeworld
so um the redemptionist entire side
doesn't it doesn't it doesn't ultimately
does not matter
and um
that's a big thing but it brings up the
question it brings up the question
if the game knows this and the game has
this pop-up at the end where it's like
everybody problem can't be solved right
who built the game
right so it has to be a faction in ETO
it couldn't have been the redemptionist
right because the redemptionist thought
that through body problem could be
solved they knew it could be solved it
has to be someone
yeah yeah but we're not going to get
into it entirely because it's probably
going to be revealed later in the show
but yeah
um someone says the game makes no sense
either if you are going to conquer a
planet why send the planet your War plan
ahead of time
well that's the thing about the
trissolerance that's a very
spoiler alert that's the thing about uh
the farmer's race is in this get we get
to this in uh the second book as well is
that they don't really get deception
they don't really get it that's not a
thing that they've evolved to have a
need for and then we understand even
more clearly why I think we get some we
get some understanding of that at the
ending of this first book we understand
why it's just it just has to do with the
biology of the Lord right so um that'll
be more explained later they they have
problems with deception telling lies is
not something they evolved to be able to
do
mm-hmm
so yeah I mean but I have questions
about the game too the game is a little
bit like uh what is what is up with the
game not not exactly everything is
answered but you know it's more about
the concept than like the literal like
oh this is a literal game and literal
whatever you know what I mean
that's the thing I always say about
science fiction is that you know
the thing about science fiction is that
it's not possible most of the time right
um for instance if if you're a fan of
Star Trek right the hollow deck doesn't
make any sense right the hollow deck I
mean it makes sense from within Universe
kind of but the hollow deck how are we
constantly walking and not hitting the
wall it's like uh the hollow deck can
make like physical structures have like
actual
you know weight and you know what I mean
it could it can it's not just holiday so
it's like how is that's not possible you
know warp speed probably isn't possible
um lightsabers are not something that's
possible
um and that goes for every sign piece of
Science Fiction I feel like well most
science there's some science fiction
which is really trying to extrapolate
um you know logically how we make this
happen but always at some point in time
you're doing some bit of speculation
you're making something up because like
we don't have that technology in the
real world right so I mean there is the
fiction side to that and I think it's a
lot of times people say oh this is a
plot hole in science fiction because
that's not possible
um like it's not it's not a plot hole
it's just it's the conceit that you have
to make when you're reading it uses okay
you know I have to accept that this is
the way this universe works you know
it's not my universe it's the fictional
Universe the science fiction part yeah
so um yeah
anyway back to episode 20 so we learned
how Wei Chang and Sean you say match
um and it had all to do with the right
problem and then
right at the end
Shanice dies
killed by the Adventist
uh and yeah so shawnifa is out of the
picture this is It's essentially what
happens in the book as well except the
events in the book are a little bit
rearranged like in the book it's more
like
dies
and then her husband goes to Joshua and
he's like someone's trying to kill me
and then that's why that's how we get
his side of the story so it's like a
little bit switched around and we also
don't don't learn that yeah wenji is the
leader of ETO at this point there is no
train sequence
um that happens a little bit later after
Wayne comes out of the game game for the
last time then we get the scene with
yeah with you so like things are mixed
up the same things are happening that
happen in the book but things are a
little bit like
twist it around which is fine I'm like
it makes it a little bit more fun to
watch not knowing exactly how everything
is going to play out
so
whoopsies poor poor shiny Faye
we hardly knew her
F in the chat F in the chat
poor poor shawnifee
you know she was pretty cool you know I
like the character
I like the character she's obsessed
obsessed I think a lot of people in the
three buddy problem
Universe become obsessed in fact I think
obsession is a pretty big theme
in this universe and right and to think
about it when you really think about how
much the role of obsession plays in this
series it's almost lovecraftian to an
extent so I did when we did the video on
the on the master races of the Universe
on the main Channel Quinn's ideas we
were talking about that guy in the third
book way to became obsessed with the
black hole right and then we talk about
the scientist and this first book who
become obsessed and commit suicide it's
almost
lovecraftian right it's like you look
into the abyss and the abyss stares back
into you it's like they've stared into
this like awful secret of the universe
and the obsession kind of consumes them
like it's consuming them it's all
consuming
I just think that's really interesting
I wonder
um why that seems to be something that's
on uh's mind
because I feel like um I think I think I
get where she Schindler is coming from
too with this concept because it's like
they often say it's been said that like
if you're intelligent if you're an
intelligent person
that you know life is just kind of going
to be a little bit more difficult for
you because it's like
in reality kinda sucks right ignorance
is bliss as they say so when it's uh
once you know things you can't kind of
put that back in the box once you know
that you're gonna die you know that
you're gonna die once you know that you
know the World's Gonna Be invaded like
you know that you can't put that back in
the Box you can't go back to living as
if you didn't know that you know what I
mean people that like you know analyze
things and you know extrapolate things
to their ultimate end like a lot of
times have a really hard time just like
being calm and just like dealing things
and not getting obsessed and not getting
like kind of depressed with like the
nature of reality you know if you just
sit down and you really really think
about the world I mean it's it's kind of
easy to get a really like it's kind of
easy to get the impression that things
are going like really really bad and
like how are we gonna fix this to the
point where it's like easier just to
like not think about it but I I think
there's a certain there's some people
and I'm like this sometimes like it's
like you notice like problems in the
world or you notice like that things are
kind of not going good and it's like you
kind of can't stop thinking about it
it's kind of it becomes ingrained right
that is it I feel like that could lead
to
you know kind of like Obsession right
you got like this you got um
shiny face husband
who's obsessed with solving this problem
he's obsessed with it where is he it's
obsessed so yeah
someone says he knows how to write
characters but the Lord doesn't care
yeah that's the thing the Lord doesn't
care
oh that's a good point um Essence ditch
Lucian does not write character he
writes ideas and he has to make people
talk about the ideas
I think that's true I think that uh
logician is not a character guy he's not
like a George RR Martin
um he has
he loves science I think logician loves
loves loves science he loves scientific
Concepts and he's very interested in
exploring those Concepts and sharing
those ideas and not really interested in
like creating a story
um creating a narrative not really
interested in like
giving the characters that much
personality or like backstory or
anything like that
someone says his characters are
extremely romantic people that is true
that is true
I see that a lot
totally get that and especially with uh
that that continues throughout the books
I feel like uh with uh shangzin
definitely very romantic character uh I
don't Luigi later on
not so much Luigi's a little bit cynical
I feel like
um I definitely definitely definitely a
lot of the mark
someone says breaking away from the
orbit of the sun is a lot simpler
Direction than breaking away from
trisolar Gravity
true
um I assume you're referencing
logician's wondering Earth which I just
covered that short story over on the
main Channel if you have not seen it
it's a cool short story uh written by
logician about
Earth in the future and we find out that
the sun is going to suddenly expand and
we gotta get the heck out of Dodge so
they decide to move the entire planet
and that's another one where you get a
bunch of people say like oh that's
impossible that could happen but it's
like hey hey it's a what if that's the
point of Science Fiction it's like what
if we could do this like how potentially
would we make it work so and what
potentially would happen right and so
that's a cool one
thank you James for linking that in the
chat let's see
what else happens we'll be right back
give me one second I gotta go get some
water we'll be right back guys
two minutes
from the abyss
I am back
someone says ironically wandering Earth
isn't even the best short story in the
wandering Earth book interesting
interesting indeed
I hear
The Village teacher is really good
that's the one I'm going to read next
very curious to see
other stories from shashinla right sorry
we I have a bunch of the books we're
gonna go through some of them I'm gonna
get to ball lightning and Supernova era
something fun
and I'm also probably going to be
watching the wandering Earth movie so
there's two of them out now so there's
wandering Earth one and wondering Earth
two so I will get those watched and we
will come here and review those on the
channel
um so these are I'm pretty sure they're
loose adaptations of the graphic novel
because the graphic novel is well the
short story and the graphic novel are
kind of short it's just like one short
story and this is two movies so is it
like the whole thing is it the whole
thing I feel like they're they've got a
add characters right I hear the the
movie is more International where it's
like the uh
uh the short story is more focused on
China so
I'm definitely gonna watch it and it's
gonna be exciting
all right someone says one is kind of
cheesy the movie is painful to watch
well I guess I'll just have to make that
decision for myself and see what's going
on
someone says the village teacher was
made into a film as well but the story
was totally changed well that's my
philosophy is if the story is totally
changed and I don't even give it a
chance right if someone tells me that an
adaptation happened and it's totally
different
I'm not going to give it that much of a
chance because why why are you calling
it an adaptation if you're going to
change everything then it's not even an
adaptation
ball lightning is great dinghy is in it
too I did hear that so dinghy is
yangdong's love interest in three body
and ball lightning is the prequel to
three body and it involves that
character he's the main character so
yeah
someone oh the second movie in wandering
Earth is apparently much better than the
first one
nice
so I don't know if you guys can hear
that but there's a fire station near my
home so
you probably hear those Sirens Maybe
Alan's drum sets it's a very loose
prequel yeah I also heard that because I
hear things that some of the things that
happen in three body
maybe like contradict it a little bit or
it's like not really like 100 one-to-one
lining up so
I'm not sure I have not read it but yeah
so yeah what else did you guys like
about the last five episodes so yeah I
thought I thought these episodes kept me
definitely engaged
it's definitely interested I'm happy
that like these episodes I I like every
episode
to add something I like every episode to
move something forward and I feel like
these last five we've really had uh
points
where we move things forward right so we
got episode 16 we learned about Mike
Evans we learn about the factions of ETO
episode 17 we get we learned about yeah
wenji
as the commander of ETO episode 18 we
learned the real
um the real point of the red Coast base
learn what that was all about episode 19
we meet Mike Evans for the first time we
learn about like oh wait Chang's
backstory episode 20
um uh we um
we get the death of Shawnee Shawnee Faye
and then we learn that the three bodies
on unsolvable right so I feel like every
single episode The every last five every
single episode these last five has added
something to the story it has moved at
least some plot forward and I feel like
that is what I need in a show right
um I felt like some of the like early on
episodes like when we were when we were
reviewing one through ten I kept saying
that they were like circling the same
plots over and over again because some
of those episodes felt like they were
just like doing the same thing over
again doing the same thing and over
again doing the same thing over again
and it's like you would get from episode
to episode like knowing nothing new
right and if you feel like nothing's
changed in the story but here we're not
at that point anymore and it's really
really moving and that makes me very
excited for what happens next I'm
excited to watch um episode 21 tonight
or maybe more if I can get access to the
other episodes maybe we'll watch several
tonight
someone says episode 26 almost get me to
cry almost get me cried well that's
that's good to know I'm excited I'm
excited I'm excited
someone says I'm hopeless I was in love
with Yao wenji I really like the actress
that plays young Yao wenji I think she's
really pretty for one I think she's
really really good I think she's
basically the embodiment of the
character so yeah
mm-hmm
yeah so I actually really liked the
scene I don't think I have a screenshot
shot of it but the scene in episode
20 where they go back into the game and
then they actually figure out this guy
creates the model that figures out that
the three body problem is actually not
solvable we can't solve it
um it's a really good scene and I think
that's it
for the game unless they diverge from
the book if I'm not mistaken I think
that's it for the game and I think now
we move on to the big boy stuff and then
hopefully at the end I don't know how
many of you have watched to the end I
haven't yet but I'm hoping
that the triceleran parts
look good right so when we get to the
the farmer's Home world and if we see
all that stuff I'm hoping that all that
looks good I'm very very very excited to
see that more so than anything probably
I'm excited to see like that because
like my imagination while reading that
like I don't even I barely know what I
imagine it's almost like like I said
that section where we finally see the
farmer's Home world it's written as
though a human is speaking but the thing
that's speaking is not by any in any
shape of the imagination
it's not um it's not human right so it's
like it's that that to me is really cool
someone says it's gonna look crappy well
I mean you gotta give it a chance first
You Gotta Give a chance first
give it a chance first
all right because I have not seen it
someone says where can I find the show
I've been watching on YouTube's tencent
Channel they only have up to episode 12
I think
I think it's I think um they release
them differently if you're not a member
of their channel so that's the deal
right so if you were a member of the
channel then
you would have more episodes so that's I
think that's the deal so I think the
rest of the episodes will be released at
some point in the future you just have
to wait that's what it is
so yeah someone says I just hope they
don't have four limbs I don't know I
mean there's a lot of ways you could
portray it and then there's a lot of
ways that the Betrayal could go totally
wrong and not look that good but you
know I got my fingers crossed I don't
know what they're gonna do and also like
I also don't know what the Netflix show
is going to do
um because
I'm just gonna say this people in charge
of the Netflix show um David benioff Dan
Weiss
based on what I saw in Game of Thrones
are not the most creative people right
so they basically
um
the thing that happened when they were
in charge of Game of Thrones is that you
would have like this really awesome
scene described in the book and then
they would take that scene strip it of
most of the things that made it really
interesting and cool and go for this
like really stylized thing even if it
didn't make sense I feel like their
philosophy when it came to that sort of
stuff was always like look cool over
making sense look cool over making sense
and I feel like it would be a total
shame if they bring that same type of
to me lack of creativity to this show
because that would that would be really
annoying right because we need things to
to more than look cool right
we need it to
make total sense especially with
something like this especially with
three body right one of the most
interesting and cool science fiction
series that I've read in a really really
long time
um
we need everybody to be on their a game
so I hope when it comes to the Netflix
adaptation that David and Dan have
learned a little bit from Game of
Thrones and I hope they're willing to
give
other people the rains more often more
people that I hope other people have
more input on it right and I hope it's
more like they're the show Runners but
other people have the creative Direction
other people are really like driving it
so someone says Quinn do you subscribe
to Dark Forest Theory you mean in real
life
hmm
well
I don't know I mean I feel like it
sounds plausible but if if
it's kind of depressing right if like
you actually like believe it I mean I
mean the only answer I can give is I
don't know
like because I mean we don't have any
it's more of a we're throwing around the
word theory it's more of a when it comes
to you know like science it's a
hypothesis right it's a it's a
hypothesis it's not a theory we don't
have that we don't have any actual
evidence that it is the case
so I really can't like say that I like
totally subscribe to it or believe in it
because we don't
have
evidence that it's actually true so I
mean that's all I can really say about
it
but if it it does I will say I will say
that the Dark Forest hypothesis totally
seems plausible but that could just also
be the fact that we're coming at this
from a very human perspective maybe the
maybe it's because you know we're humans
we view the world in a certain way
unless we view the universe in a certain
way like our thinking is informed by you
know millions of years of evolution you
know we've we've got the ape brains you
know what I mean so like
we're paranoid creatures like we humans
are naturally paranoid of the outside of
the other so of course that like seeps
into you know like sometimes how we
write things you know electrician isn't
the first person to you know write about
the potential of the Dark Forest
hypothesis we talked about
um
we talked about Charles Pellegrino
The Killing star on this channel and
there's other people that have written
about this I think um in the early 80s
so um
La wasn't the first person to you know
think that up
but I mean I'm sure like even before the
early 80s that someone had thought about
that idea too but um
do I believe it I can't say I believe it
but I get why it's plausible that's why
I'm getting that that's what I'm getting
at someone says we are bugs
um
someone says does anyone know what movie
Wang me out and his daughter were going
to watch at the end of episode 21 was it
2001 A Space Odyssey I have not seen
episode 21 yet so I don't know this is
episode 16 through 20 review I have not
seen episode 21.
the flute says I do like the Dark Forest
Theory
um
we need to be cautious like very
cautious
foreign
well I do agree with the idea of being
cautious I think it is a little weird
that we
send signals in outer space and we don't
know what's out there that is kind of
like
I don't know going on to the dark web
and like broadcasting your address or
something like that I guess it's a
little weird we don't know what's out
there and you know if there is malicious
stuff just on our own planet that like
wants to kill us so we gotta assume kind
of that there's malicious stuff outside
our planet right right
foreign
I don't know maybe maybe
most life in the universe this is just
crazy speculation now but maybe like we
we're totally wrong and that most life
in the universe doesn't evolve on
planets maybe most life in the universe
evolves in the vacuum and it's too
different for us to like actually
understand it or see it as life maybe
this weird kind of life that we are that
needs to consume mother life to continue
is actually
weird maybe we're the weird ones right
maybe the cosmos is actually full of
life that's incomprehensible to us and
undetectable to us that that doesn't
even care about us that doesn't even
know we're here you know what I mean
yeah I mean we could be the outlier in
all this you know I feel like the
universe is so big
and I feel like just reality is so
expansive that like almost anything
could be true
I mean when when we actually really
really think about
how little we actually know in terms of
like what the universe is how it even
exists why something exists rather than
nothing when we actually like start to
really think about these things I really
think that it's like it kind of just we
don't know anything
we don't know anything I think we make a
lot of really arrogant assumptions as
people but
we're in a tiny little bubble
um in a tiny little region of space
you know you know in a galaxy that's
honestly in a tiny little region of
space and our sun is constantly moving
around this Galaxy and this galaxy is
constantly just hurtling through space
like we're never in the same spot uh
that to me this was the really
interesting part about the third book in
the three body problem series deaths end
right so there is a scene in that book
where like the Earth just for a short
period of time moves into
an area where it comes into contact with
a bubble of the fourth dimension right
and just for that period of time
I don't want to spoil it but just for
that short period of time magic was
possible unexplicable things could
happen because of just Earth colliding
with this fourth dimensional fragment
right and it was only because
the Earth is is not in the same place
all the time right the Earth is
constantly moving through space moving
through space
um and maybe we're moving through
different things like maybe we're like
like we could move through like a
different way I don't know I'm getting
really weird and speculative right but
maybe we move into a region of space
that you know is inhabited by like I
don't know life forms that live in the
vacuum and we're like we pass through
them and that affects us in some weird
way or we like move through some region
of space that's like full of like a
certain type of matter that like affects
us in a weird way I know there's no
evidence for any of that and it's all
speculation but the point is anything
could just be floating out in space and
we can run into it at any point in time
and we might not be able to understand
it or or know how to like categorize it
in our brain right so I just finished
doing my video on Annihilation Jeff
Vandermeer and it's basically about
Earth's encounter with this thing that
we can't understand and it's changing
everything around us we don't know why
we don't know what it wants we can't
understand it and it's just it's so
weird I mean I just think about like
the kid in elementary school that stumps
on an ant hill does the ant understand
what the flip is going on the ant the
ant is just like oh my the hill is
destroyed and I don't know why the hills
destroyed out there comes another foot I
don't know why that just happened
um so I just
I think what makes three body
the series scary it's just the idea that
we don't know anything right so when
you're reading these books every time it
expands every time our perception is
expanded it's a little bit terrifying
right when we learn about you know what
else is out there I want to give it away
but the more we learn
the scarier it gets the more we learn
like the more questions we have about
like oh well that's truth and what does
that say about this and what does that
say about this that's why I love this
book
someone says Annihilation movie is
greater than the book I happen to like
both I I like the book for the love
crafting elements and I like the movie
because it's a great science fiction
movie and it's always nice when we get a
great science fiction movie
um
me
technical Pinnacle says is there going
to be a season two for three body well
from what I hear it's pretty popular in
China so I mean that's the way American
shows work when it's popular then I mean
we get a season two but I don't know I
don't know what that depends on
ultimately I hope so because I'd
definitely be fun to watch this
definitely be fun to watch Dark Forest
next year
oh someone says true harm says I heard
they already started season two
I didn't hear that but if that's true
then freaking awesome
um we're getting a lot of character
actually the crazy thing is
season two we would only have Dasha
dashia will return and then we would
have yawinji returning for a bit but
none of these other guys would be back
Wang's not in the second none of these
characters
are in the second book at all
uh and then we got the time jumps that
happened in the second book and then we
got even more time Jump significant time
jumps in the third book and characters
really change I think the the only
character that's in every book
if I'm not mistaken maybe yeah wenji but
the only character that's in every book
is is Dasha
someone says if they do make dark Forest
it would take at least two years
I don't really know how long this show
is in the works I mean I heard about it
um but it really feels like it came out
pretty quick
someone says Quinn what would you do if
you learned the truth
the truth about what the truth about the
universe like it's like what's it called
in Rick and Morty when they go through
like the thing and it like
it's I
I forget what it's called they got the
like psychedelic trip Cosmic something I
forget like I don't know well you mean
if I was exposed to like the true like
nature of the cosmos and stuff I don't
know
it depends on how utterly terrifying it
was right like to me
I don't know it depends it depends on
what it was you know I feel like
the journey and trying to figure out the
secrets of the universe are probably
more fun than knowing so I feel like if
I like oh this is what the secret of the
universe is like eventually it'll be
like oh my God what's next I think
that's the weird thing about humanity
and the weird thing about being a person
right is that
I don't know we're always like what's
next we're always like what's next which
is why like Infinity is super weird
because I feel like
no matter how much you achieve and no
matter what you do you're always going
to be like what's next what's next
what's next and then we've when we when
we try to perceive an affinity like if
you think about living forever that
concept is really like scary to a person
or at least to me right because it's
like
constantly be moving and they constantly
just keep
that that idea is just freaky freakishly
terrifying to me it's like the constant
existence but then on the flip side of
that the idea of of annihilation
obliteration Oblivion
you know death not existing it's also as
existentially terrifying right so like
the the idea of existing forever and
also the idea of ending in my mind
are both
just horrible just just freakish to me
right yeah and that is the human dilemma
or at least that's my dilemma that's my
dilemma
what are we talking about in the chat
here
[Music]
um
someone says the expression of love in
Chinese culture is very implicit and
does not like kissing in public
interesting interesting it's been very
interesting to to hear from Chinese
followers of mind
um just like little tidbits about
Chinese culture because all of the
little bits of information about Chinese
culture helped me to help inform my
perception of this series
um and this show right and I think
that's that's really really helpful
because there's a lot of things that to
me as an American to me as an outsider
that like
um I mean that might go over my head
right so it's really good to have like
you guys helping me out and like giving
me the context for some of the things
like for instance the Dasha dancing
thing I didn't get that until like some
of you guys like explained
um what that meant what square dancing
meant so right to me that's just like a
square dancing that's to me to me like
square dancing is like
um a very very Southern American thing
you know you see that in like Texas or
Alabama or where I'm from Georgia
um it's a very like
Caucasian southern thing right so it was
like not like
something that I was exposed to very
often and it's curious to see like what
that means in China you know it's
interesting
it's very very interesting
uh let's see
someone says paying to watch the last 10
of 10 episodes is only for a limited
time all right so if you pay you have to
like basically binge them
and then it goes back off that's a
little weird I've never seen it be done
like that anywhere else
all right so you guys have anything else
say about these last five episodes
before we wrap things up
um a square dance for us now Quinn I
wouldn't even begin to know how to
square dance I wouldn't even begin to
know
someone says it's a money crab kind of
seems money grabby if I'm not gonna lie
doesn't seem seems a bit money gravity
I'm not gonna lie yeah
someone says Wang shows little affection
towards his wife well in the show he
shows more affection towards her uh than
in the book in the book like he like
totally ignores her I feel like it's
like she's barely a character in the
book
um re-upping an earlier question the
show had changed things by giving access
to panhand's computer
um
I don't know what what you're
referencing
show it changed things by giving us
access to panhand's computer I don't
know what you're referencing exactly
someone says is the tele is the
telescope comic relief guy gone now yeah
what happened to that guy he seemed like
he was just like a major player at first
and now I don't know I I probably just
like
I'm not gonna say it I'm not gonna say
it's like weird like how the scientists
you know they've been like
committing suicide I'm just thinking
like maybe just like
I don't know often so that's not even
funny why am I laughing at it's not even
funny but yeah he was kind of annoying
just a little bit but I don't know what
was up with that actor there was also
like some a couple of adverts that were
playing
um during some of the earlier episodes
that he was in
so I thought like maybe he was like
maybe like a famous comedy actor in
China and then that was like
that's why he was also in like the funny
advert or whatnot
but yeah
someone says he's not dead in the show
no he's not I don't think he's dead that
was just I don't think he's actually
dead
he's hanging out somewhere he's off
doing his thing still trying to figure
it out still trying to figure it out
someone says was anybody if else
affected by reading the book the first
time we all became aware of it I'm in
Australia and for the first time it
seemed like we were trying to fight off
dooming ourselves in early 2022. yeah I
mean after I read the three buddy
problem series I was very affected by it
it was one of those things where I could
not stop thinking or talking about it
and I always know when I read something
that I can't stop talking or thinking
about it that I need to make a video
would Quinn be an Adventist or
redemptionist if I had to be
um if I had to join ETO I would probably
be if I didn't know all the information
I guess I would have to be a
redemptionist because I would more like
want
I would more want to help the
trisolarians fix their junk and not come
here I'd be like okay if we can help you
solve your stuff can you just leave us
alone that would be more me right I
would I'm not on the side of just like I
hate humanity and I'm definitely not on
the side of like I just want to survive
and you know screw everybody else so I
feel like redemptionist redemptionist
seemed like the most noble to me of all
of all ETO
someone says is it me or does this show
suck I mean
everybody not everybody's gonna like
everything you know not everybody's
gonna like everything I'm sure there's
I feel like here's the thing
your favorite thing in the world the
thing that you think is like the best
thing ever it's gonna be someone else
that freaking hates it and they think it
sucks they don't like it at all they
don't like it right
um
and their favorite thing that they love
is someone that hates that too there's
somebody that hates that so I feel like
there's no there's nothing on the planet
that everybody likes like you might like
you might really love all I want for
Christmas is you uh you know there's a
lot of people that don't like that song
right
so a lot of people that don't like it
you know yeah to each his own and that's
my philosophy and I feel like that is
true in every
thing possible you know someone says
where's the dog
Fiona siona
girl
what are you doing
I think I think she died
come here
siona there she is
everybody say hi everybody say hey to
the dog
she doesn't even know that she's being
filmed right now
do you know that you're being filmed
siona
are you working with EPO siona
she's working with ETO
oh she's extremely lazy you have no idea
extremely lazy
just look at it
it's like okay I'm going back to bed now
leave me alone
get out of here get out of here
someone says where exactly is the Sci-Fi
in the show
have you not been watching the same show
this show is more sci-fi than most like
Science Fiction American movies
like I guess at this point it's like I
guess at this point it's just like
straight up science like they're
literally doing calculations and trying
to solve them throughout your problem
but like I mean
it's it's a slow burn I'm not gonna lie
and say it's not a slow burn but I mean
like yeah
I did wake her up I think though so okay
so Quinn have you heard about the
Stargate review Stargate review I have
not reviewed
as I reviewed Stargate reboot I have not
heard about that that's that's pretty
cool
okay anyway guys
I think it's time we got going I think
we covered
we we had a nice discussion on the last
five episodes I thought they were really
entertaining uh We've really gotten
going with the story it's gonna be
exciting to watch the next 10 episodes
from here on out
um yeah yeah yeah so just been really
fun
um just watching the show so far and
thanks guys uh make sure you like this
video if you've been watching the whole
time just hit the like button it really
helps out hello to all of the people on
Billy Billy I see you over there
I noticed that in the Billy Billy
comments
now it translates to station B
is station B what Billy Billy is called
in China
I don't know it could be a problem with
translation but I know like all of my
streams get uploaded to Billy Billy and
they get way more views at least my
streams
do the streams that I put here get way
more views on Billy Billy than they do
on this channel
this is the way more popular but anyway
thank you guys everybody all around the
world that's enjoying the content check
out my main Channel Quinn's ideas if you
have not check it out I'm sure most of
you have anyway peace out guys thanks
for watching thanks for sitting here
with me
and yeah